hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar easy automation
solutions better results I am Judy
Oracle leverage and I'll be moderating
this session today is educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing science at the
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by beckman coulter life sciences
this webinar is actually the first
presentation in a three-part series on
laboratory automation solutions for
smaller labs and those less familiar
with automation who are interested in
standardizing workflows and saving costs
through improved efficiency and results
this year of Beth men culture life
sciences is celebrating 30 years in
automation as they continue to provide
liquid handling solutions to help
accelerate reliable results that drive
scientific discovery Beckman offers a
full range of flexible and scalable
biomech automated workstations and
integrated systems automate genomic
cellular protein and other works or
flows in a wide variety of research
areas including agriculture cancer and
infectious diseases cardiovascular
forensics and neurodegenerative
disorders for genomic applications
biomech automated workstations are
complemented by growing portfolio of
nucleic acid extraction and purification
kits those on the company's patented
solid-phase reversible immobilization as
PRI magnetic bead technology let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits you can post
questions to the speakers during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind did you so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the prison
asian window or report your problem by
clicking on green Q&A button at lower
left I now present today's speakers
David Horvath MS and Zack Smith ms or
both senior applications scientists for
beckman coulter life sciences david
automates propriety and third-party next
generation sequencing chemistry he has
Masters of Science in medical and
molecular genetics from the Indiana
University School of Medicine David's
career experiences span a broad range of
life science fields including forensic
DNA analysis medical diagnostics and
agricultural biotechs Zac automates
propriety and third-party
next-generation sequencing tips he has
masters in environmental science from
Indiana University previously exact
worked at the University Center for
genomics and bioinformatics is a project
scientist David will now begin this
presentation thank you thank you to all
of our attendees glad to have you with
us this morning or I guess evening
depending on where you're at as Julie
mentioned this is part one of the
three-part webinar series and so today
we'll be talking about introducing your
customers to automating NGS workflows
will continue in June with the second
part of DNA and RNA sequencing sample
prep and then go into a little more
detail on specific method ranging from
simple to complex the third part of the
series is entitled mission possible
automating NGS sample prep for
challenging samples and nisha
application so we'll be discussing some
of the applications that are becoming
available for niche markets and how we
address challenges manual processing for
those chemistry's
okay so again we want to talk about what
a typical ng has workflow is and typical
is in quotes for a reason because there
really isn't a typical and GS workbook
in general though it follows this
workflow that we have on the slide you
start with cdna synthesis for RNA seek
applications and then continuing from
there you have your traditional library
construction steps which will include
and repair a tailing ligation of the
adapters and subsequent cleanups after
each of those steps PCR enrichment is
optional for certain workflows and
depending on the workboat target capture
is also an optional part of an NGS
workflow following the traditional
library prep construction you will
continue on to do library QC
quantitation and sequencing preparation
and the actual sequencing run itself so
although most NGS workflows follow this
consistent path the specific workbook
and very bravely for each application
they can range from single day short and
simple protocol to multi day highly
complex protocols even though the
workflows can vary greatly they all
shared common elements such as reagent
and vine transfers sample transfers
fee-based sample cleanup and or site
selection as well as the recycling and
incubation reactions so we focused on
the modularity of those common elements
and optimize those and then construct
them in different ways to basically
assemble the workload for each
individual application here we have some
workflow examples of a simple NGS
workflow or the rubicon genomics through
plex plasma speed chemistry the protocol
takes approximately three and a half
hours to complete it's performed in a
single plate for all the reactions
and there's a limited number of start
and stop points so it's relatively
simple manual process and also a
relatively simple application on the
automation as well the first column here
at a little bit are beyond the detail
that's basically your library
construction and the second column is an
optional cleanup following your library
construction the next example gets into
more I guess a typical workflow as far
as complexity is concerned and this
example is for the alumina to seek nano
DNA chemistry it's approximately a
one-day protocol it involves multiple
reactions and clean up plates and has
multiple start start and stop points and
to continue on to a difficult or highly
complex method example this is an
example of the alumina true Sikh RNA
access method which is approximately a
three-day protocol and includes target
capture following library construction
or adapter ligation and it has an
increasingly larger number of labrum
consumables due to the overall length of
the process and it's highly complex with
numerous start and stop points so again
all these workflows follow a series of
reaction setups incubations clean ups
etc it's just the length of the
application and the complexity of how
those steps are pieced together to
create the overall workflow so if you're
already processing if you're already
processing NGS samples by hand you know
the challenges of the NGS workflow so
some of those challenges are significant
amount of manual pipetting steps so with
the significant amount of pipetting you
have higher variability especially with
clean up such as adapter cleanups or
your final sample
often it requires skilled pipetting so
what I mean by that is transferring of
viscous liquid in well tip mixing or
preventing magnetic be carryover while
transferring supernatant off of a play
manual pipetting steps can also
contribute to user fatigue and injury
manual processing is highly aeropro some
examples would be sample and or index
transfer mix-ups sample normalization
errors master mix recipe calculation
errors and pipette volume setting errors
so basically saying if I've been to the
wrong Bonnie affecting reaction
chemistry b ratios etc that are
important for cleanup or recite
selections in addition manual processing
provides limited throughput and reduced
data generation small labs or any lab
for that matter as always there always
limited in personnel resources how many
people you have to get the work done
whether you have a small amount of work
or a large amount of work people always
a limiting factor in how much you can
get done ok often there's more effort
spent on routine sample processing
versus more value adding data analysis
so automation can minimize or eliminate
all of these challenges so with that
being said that can culture would like
to think that every lab we want to
automate so we hear from customers
they're not ready to automate and here
are several reasons that they give as to
why they're not ready to make that jump
from manual processing to automated
processing we are too small well
automation reduces the effort of routine
processing it increases productivity
even with limited personnel resources so
to allow your your small labs with
limited number of personnel to be able
to do more work more effectively
again the able to focus on the value
adding data analysis work versus routine
sample processing lab also senator
throughput is not high enough justify
automating well throughput is not the
only reason for automation the
automation provides more accurate and
reproducible sample data irrespective of
sample numbers and is scalable to match
the last growing be some last field that
they shut their people more than
machines so biomech applications are
demonstrated and qualified with data to
support robust performance and I'll talk
a little bit later about how our
development process works for our
applications and the types of data that
you generate to support those claims in
the performance of the application
budget budgets they're always limited
whether you're a small lab or a large
lab so automation can provide
significant savings over manual
processing through reduced labor or
overtime pay reduced rework caused by
human error and reduce consumable usage
via efficient blabber and tip handling
so encourage labs to look at the big
picture of how automation can fit into
their workflow and provide an overall
cost savings as compared to manual
processing and lastly we don't have the
expertise to operate and maintain
laboratory automation so by Microsoft
Word is full-featured and easy to use
which makes it the right solution for
either the knowledge or experience user
okay so for the middle portion of the
presentation we're going to talk about
what Becca culture does to develop an
application so we're going to start with
market research followed by building
collaborative partnerships scoping the
requirements and features of the
application and then begin the
development process where we develop and
optimize the method test and method with
real reagents and
data and then produce content such as
tech notes application notes posters
webinar such as this which go through an
internal and external review process
that's followed by insulation the
applications at the customer site and
then post installation support it's all
over some details unto those parts of
our development process to start with we
have market research we're looking out
into the field to see what applications
are in demand and we gather that
feedback from various places whether
that's trade shows customers
publications journal articles etc to see
what people are doing in their research
and we utilize that to set a queue up to
prioritize which applications we're
going to focus on development when we
select the applications develop we want
to build collaborative partnerships with
the chemistry vendors and key research
institutions so there are great
partnerships we work to ensure that the
the chemistry is being automated in in
the manner in which it was intended to
be wrong manually so working with the
chemistry vendors to ensure that the
data quality comes out automated the
same as it does manually is not better
and we partner with key research
institutions customers who are either
using this chemistry already by hand or
have an interest in automating this
chemistry in their lab and we use them
as a the real world case example for
processing these samples in a customer's
lab so we generate get it together and
ensure that through that partnership
that we have a robust and reliable
solution to go out through our broader
customer base so as those collaborations
are made the next step is to scope out
the requirements and features for the
particular application
the goal is to develop a template method
that can be readily deploy the customers
a template method is going to be a
method that covers the majority of
options and workflows that we expect to
see out in the field but still be
flexible enough to offer configuration
for user specific needs once it gets out
into the field we focus on things such
as throughput capacity walk away time we
consider various accessories and
integrated devices that are required to
perform the various workflow steps
workflow options such as sample number
save stop points any type of manual
interactions for the cycle that I think
it is all those are considered while
scoping out the method as well as the
instrument platform selection so I'll
talk about our instrument platforms we
have multiple configurations which
provide flexible throughput and
capabilities to handle any NGS workflow
the biomech 4000 is our introductory
been shot model it's sized just right
for web comedian throughput labs
typically we develop applications
anywhere from 1 to 24 sample done on
this instrument while I can handle
greater numbers of samples usually
limited to that number so that walk away
capability and efficiency is still
realized on that platform it has a pot
that has interchangeable pipetting tools
so there's single tools and eight
channel pipetting heads it also has
interchangeable rivers so you can have
the ability to move laughs we're on the
deck and not have them be fixed in one
spot the neck layout below is the is a
typical example of our ngf set up for
the bottleneck 4000 it includes an
orbital shaker static healthy a device
for keeping agents cho the next platform
is our biomech nxp
that's going to be our mid-sized unit
it's capable of medium to high
throughput workflows up to 96 samples it
has various pod options is a single pod
which can be either a span 8 or a
multi-channel pod the multi-channel
having options for either 96 or 384-well
head but also have the capability of
enhanced multi selective tip pipetting
which is a multi-channel head that has
capability to pipette single rose single
columns or even individual wells so it
provides some flexibility of a span
system while still providing the
efficiency of a multi-channel head
there's approximately 16 dec physicians
and a highly customizable Dex allowing
an increasing capacity over the biomat
4000 and again an example of our typical
NGS deck set up below with a static
pelletier in the back left corner
there's an orbital shaker in the back
middle trash chute on the right and the
two positions on the far left are
stacking positions that increases
capacity for additional tip storage or
play storage and lastly we move into our
biomech FXP which is our largest
platform it's a high-throughput it's a
fitting system for Hydra what our
complex workflows up to 96 samples or
more that's the stress that the sizes or
the amount of throughput you have inside
of your lab doesn't necessarily dictate
the size of the instrument that would be
right for you if the workflow
requirements for your particular
application required a lot of cleanups
and a lot of enzyme transfers than
having a duel bot system regardless of
throughput or total capacity is still
beneficial to your lab so the public FXP
can be configured with the combination
of two pod multi-channel 96 or 384-well
head as well as the span a pod you can
have two multi channels a multi-channel
in the span and the option of those and
the dagda's Holly configurable it offers
a large of decks and
and X or the bottom of 4000 with
approximately 20 dec position the
example NGS deck layout that we have
below includes the integrated T robot
which is our integrated thermal cycler
on the left there's a wash station in
the back row on the left which allows
for reuse of tips after transfers an
orbital shaker and then also static
healthy a device to keep rageous chilled
as well continuing on the scoping
options and things that are considered
when when developing a method we have
options for lab or selection heating and
cooling orbital shaking and syd mixing
and tip utilization so adverse selection
could be two versus plates what's the
right lab work for your application can
be based on sample number dead volume in
the tube what capacity you need for your
sample we have options for reagent
reservoirs whether there's a full plate
reservoir we have module runs doors as
as shown in the center picture below
which can hold different volumes of
reagents based on the amount needed for
each application the right modular
reservoir is matched to the volume to
reduce dead volume there's a necessary
magnetic plate for deep separation the
example picture on the bottom left there
and then thermocycler lids might be
another lab word option that's needed
with integrated thorough cycling under
tech there's consideration for tip
mixing versus shaking workable shaking
delivers fast efficient plate mixing it
reduces tip usage and provides uniform
results whereas tip mixing works well
for larger volumes it prevents
cross-contamination with lab weird
that's a Dornier well capacity so if you
have a well that's almost full orbital
shaving isn't the right options for that
particular next step so tip mixing will
be deployed for those purposes aunt in
mixing can also access tubes or lab word
that are not compatible
with orbital death or with an orbital
shaker deck like a 65 for aluminum tube
rack heavy aluminum to rack that will
not spit on our orbital shaker heating
and cooling options pelletier units are
easy to use the heat and cool there's
various adapters that can be fit on to
the surface of the pelletier to
accommodate various Labrador so round
bottom weld flat bottom pcr adapters etc
there's open it's an open position so
there's no place feeling so
considerations have to be made or higher
temperatures and evaporation there is a
slower ramping and cooling speed and
service eichler's have and it's not all
an ideal for all applications such as
high temperatures because of evaporation
issues thorough cycling can be
integrated it can be integrated on all
of our platforms spot mic for dynamics t
or F XP and the thermal cycle is
provided to operate solution not having
to interact with your with a method for
every indication that you need to
perform and familiar with some of the
longer applications there's multiple
incubations that take place in which
would require multiple user
interventions for off deck their
recycling so this allowed the instrument
to move the plate automatically to the
thermocycler and continue to method
without any user intervention the place
viewing lids prevent evaporation and
then the two robots are compatible with
probably use PCR lavender and we
continue to do development work to
integrate additional manufacturers the
recycling components as well so tip
selection choosing the tip size is
important depending on the type of
raising your transferring to the type of
Labrador trying to access so our just
come in various volume ranges
20 my fingers up to 1000 microliters
there staring barrier or nominee your
options and we also have conducted the
non-conductive tips which are used to
live in level sensing so tube axis is
important part of the selection of P
25th is shorter it has a higher volume
without the barrier than twenty
microliters and this might be the right
option for shallow microtiter plate
where the p50 is the longer tip some
more slender and it would work more
effectively with the deep bubbly so that
was a lab where and bedecked layout and
all the accessories and active devices
are selected for the application we then
start looking at method workflow options
so if you're familiar with our methods
you you're familiar with the user
interface that we have at the start of
the run if you're not familiar than
methods all of our methods have a user
interface and so with user interface
does is provide all the option settings
that are relevant to the specific
application it's going to have things
such as options for on or off dexter
recycling options for training mode
which allows you to quickly run through
a method without the lengthy mutations
that can be used for training or
optimization and testing new
laboratories it includes options for all
relevant applications specific options
that could be in this case and depends
for the Swift Biosciences method there's
sample input options and fragment size
options as well as which part of the
method that you're wishing to run so in
this case the PCR free portion of the
method has been selected with various
index and after transfer options all the
options are validated for proper
selection to ensure that that correct
inputs are made by the user and will not
generate errors upon execution of the
run and there's also stay stopping
points built in to these options to
allow say stopping points matching the
manufacturer's protocol ability to
safely store
at 48 points separate state stopping
points for pre and post PCR being able
to stop them that didn't transfer your
samples to a different instrument if
that happens to be the way that your
labs polling management system dictates
allows for offset incubations and safe
stop points love for recovery by being
able to perform portions of the method
or go back in the workflow to a previous
point and continue from there and lastly
other considerations that we have in the
deck for chemistry specific issues there
can be multiple issues but some examples
that we have here are considerations for
sodium hydroxide so certain reactions
are dependent on setting my jock side to
be prepared fresh so we have building
considerations for that where prompts
are presented to the user at the right
time of method to present the deck with
that particular reagent for ethanol we
have considerations over evaporation and
water ephesians to those to the ethanol
so we want to ensure that the dead
volume is correct for ethanol depending
on the length of the run walk away is
great but if you have ethanol on your
deck for an entire data and we
definitely have to have considerations
for those types of reagents so after all
those considerations are made in scoping
is set out we begin our development and
optimization process so template methods
are written to follow the manufacturer's
protocol and then we hit the lab we have
facility here in Indianapolis with
multiple instruments on all of our
platforms we use live chemistry and
we're the ultimate goal is to generate
with the kids that customers are
actually going to use so to start we do
thorough dry bedding and logistical
movement testing to make sure that the
method structure is sound that lab wars
moving where it's supposed to be
pipetting is occurring in the well at
the right depth with us from the bottom
to the top of the plate when that all
checks out we move into light creation
testing and what that is using ethanol
or glycerol solutions the mimic enzyme
transfers we are the manufacturer of our
be chemistry that you see and all that
ngf kit though we have the ability to
test be dispensing an accuracy of the D
ratios in house with our with our own
chemistry so we use real chemistry when
possible during the light reagent
testing and optimization and then we go
into optimizing and calendaring
pipetting specific to each application
or specific transfer so again with with
be clean up sighs collection vol
transfers and ratios are critically same
for any type of reaction set of the
balance of the chemistry's is critical
to the optimal performance of the
application so each of our pipetting
techniques can be dialed in to very
accurate accurate volume transfers
across the range of the pipette tip so
we spend time to make sure that that set
up as accurately as possible to generate
the most robust results following the
optimization we move into our live
chemistry testing so we've we've ensured
that the method is sound are pending
optimization is up to spec and then we
actually run real kits with real
chemistry with real samples if needed
after data generated we continue to do
optimization that we sometimes don't see
and so we
the actual chemistry and we continue to
find soon than that is until we have the
results that we're looking for so
deserving those results based on
generation of quantitative and
qualitative data such as bioanalyzer
tracing GPCR data and downstream into
the sequencing data in sequencing
metrics so next part of our process is
content generation in review and I'm
going to hand off to my colleague Zack
Smith and he's going to continue without
an all new process from this point
forward okay thank you very much did
thank you everyone for sticking with us
for this long it's done a pretty good
job so far I'm hoping to pick up where
he left off so content generation and
review process so that's where we
generate the technical and application
notes to demonstrate the method
capabilities and the robustness of our
application the first thing we'll do is
we will have the chemistry vendor go
through our our data either our QC
traces from the Bob analyzer kpt our
results or our sequencing metrics and
review those and make sure that the
chemistry vendor is content with the
results David said we have a facility
here in Indianapolis that is fully
equipped with this work we have two
sequencers in-house aluminum I seek an
annex e500 that we can use to generate
the sequencing data we need if we need
more data we have worked on a couple of
projects that required high C data we
can certainly work with the the vendors
or we send those out for additional data
analysis and then we work with the
bioinformatics groups associated with
the reagent vendors to to analyze those
data and interpret them properly the
data must meet acceptable meals meals
for metrics metrics for yield the sizing
must be accurate and the sequencing
metrics such as the percent VOR RNA and
nation if you're working with an RNA
method or the percent on target for 30
percent on target reads for a capture
method must be consistent with what the
reagent vendor is seeing in the manual
prep the other thing we look for is
evidence of cross-contamination so our
NGS methods are working with all the
plates typically which helps speed the
workflow along because then you're not
having to see your own field plates but
we do realize the possibility that I
mean this represents a risk for
cross-contamination so it's something
relation for hidden sequencing data and
it is something that you because we're
looking for it in sequencing data you
can see levels that are not detectable
on file analyzer or other fragment
analysis traces and so we feel like we
really do go one step beyond what's
typical in proving that our automation
solutions are sound and there the data
you can trust the data that's being
generated so once that review process is
done then we will generate content for
public distribution like this webinar
that you've all kinda decided to show up
for and then we'll move on to
application installation so we realized
that while we have that you know we have
instrument configurations that we that
we generally suggest for not mini has
applications that our customers are
working with so much more because our
our liquid handlers really our
application agnostic and there's their
chemistry agnostic and so you might be
doing NGS applications you might be
doing to tell you or a protein work and
so we don't force a customer to bias to
the configuration for their instruments
so we recognize that the instrument that
the applications there what we develop
need to be flexible in their design and
they can be configured properly so
during the course of application
installation our field application
specialist will go through and they will
implement the method on your instrument
and they will perform a whole range of
on-site pipetting optimizations on-site
testing frequently going
through a logistical test to make sure
the lab were moving properly that your
sack offsets are correct and then
they'll go through some pipetting
testing and actually go through a
complete water run typically whether at
a customer site so that you can verify
the pipetting is on target and then
after the application is installed we
have an entire group that provides tech
support for these applications and other
groups that provide service support for
the hardware and then we have another
third group that provides training and
post user meetings for our customers so
the reason why we do this is we it's not
like we're just going to go through an
airdrop at an application into your site
and expect you to just know how to use
it we do backstop our applications with
a very extensive group of people that do
various products to support for our
customers so there's some other
additional software features beyond
biomech software that I wanted to touch
on during the courses presentation both
of which are fairly new by magnetic
launcher being the newest but these are
software packages that we have developed
because we feel like we can help offer
and improve user experience and better
data management and handling during the
course of the method being run so you
during the course of the average day
you'll come to your biomech mule say I
want to run a method alright well are we
sure we pick the right project and am i
working with the most recent version by
method or usually what we find out is
our normal binding method or methods
environment operators on vacation and
the pea i must be run s and I really
help with this so for those reasons and
several others and by the way this is
what our standard user interface looks
like so if you were to open up this
editor on your controller this is what
you would see it's fairly
straightforward to use as far as
programming this concerned the UI gives
you a GUI based interface for building
methods and build and building out
software solutions if you want to if you
want to do that alternatively you can
use Bionic method launcher to launch
your application has been installed
already so if I'm amendment launcher is
a new product it has two components to
it one is the launcher interface what
you're seeing here and the other one is
guided lab we're set up this is the
parameter P are the two primary
components here so the launcher allows
you to interact with your instrument
without actually running the editor
software so you would just go in and
begin climbing method launcher and your
applications would be lifted out there
on the launcher and there would be icons
alike just like the right one you can
also you know perform manual control on
the instrument to the launcher as well
just by clicking down on the manual
control tab and it will bring up a whole
variety of options that you can use to
run the instrument once you've selected
your method say for example you want to
run a true side a chilly version 2 @ h
you know based user interface will pop
up and it would give you the options you
need to run the methods how many samples
you want to process and which components
of the method that you want to run we
you know we build these you eyes in such
a way that they're easy to operate and
should be fairly straightforward for any
operator to employ the other component
of violent mended launcher is a new step
up guided lab we're set up so guide lab
we're set up will step you through on a
plate by plate box by pit box process to
set the deck up and in such a way that
you know it is properly set up and one
of the things that really does nicely is
that it will go through
you side views of stacks of lab where so
you can see that on the right-hand side
of your screen and for reagents that are
deployed and troughs or you have master
mixes that you need to create all those
setup instructions are included in the
individual labrum scriptions
additionally you can print off the guide
lever sent over the PDF and you can take
those set of instructions to fax your
bench or you can go and make up your
master mixes the other thing you can do
is you can add the other thing you can
do with the cdss OPDs can be uploaded to
a lymph system for example or copied
into a lab notebook to show you know the
user visits what I've done on this
particular day it's a really powerful
interface and I might get quite a lot
actually so once you get beyond guys lap
are set up then during the courses
amended running this is what the runtime
or what the runtime interface would look
like for bio magnetic launcher so on the
Left you'll see one to beam envy method
screen where it will go through to look
into a progress bar on the top that will
show you how long yeah how long the
method is going to continue so this
answers the vital question of can i go
and get a cup of coffee or do i have
time to go to the bathroom or is it time
to interact with the instrument and then
it will go through and will offer you a
series of milestones ill let you know
what process it's working on and how
long that individual process is going to
take if you flip over to the method view
over here on the right hand side of your
screen it will actually go through and
show you the biomech steps that's
actually looking through and if you go
into the lab where dialogue which is on
the right bottom right of each of those
each of those screens you can actually
click and view the volumes on every
individual piece of lab whereas the
methods progressing so you can longer
it's it's running in real time
ah yes data anyway so i'll mention that
can generate a large number of data that
will need to be tracked just for a bit
and just one well for example this one
plate we could you know track what the
same idea is what the project idea is
what the p.i is we're working for on
this particular project what species it
is the name of the technician running
the assay concentrations all you the
list goes on and on and the issue gets
exponentially worse the more plates you
process leads to a lot of data that
needs to be handled and of course it's
not just from you know this data is
piling up during the course of numerous
applications so you're if you're
starting off with ngf samples either DNA
or RNA you'll want to know you know
where the samples were a session from
any data that's associated with them
including species or the volume of the
concentration or maybe you have to
quantify it in yourself when you get
them in and so one things you can do is
you can merge the detector data and
track the data and sample i think to the
dilution played as you quantify and
normalize the PMA then there's the
matter of doing your NGS library prep
and so that point you want to track what
samples are associated with what in
disease so that you can be multiplex
example later and then you want to
exporters some of that data interview
with an experiment manager for your
sample sheet and then also extend that
data to the lens I'll limb system if
your lab has one pronounce your analysis
so dark suit point O stands for data
acquisition and reporting tool is if I'm
that data there is a software package
that works with biomech and SQL to
generate a repository that attract all
that information
on a per plate basis so it can take
reader data it will take data from data
sets that are generated as a part of
normal operation for binding software
and it can report them out to and other
devices libsystem any web-enabled device
allowing monitor to the run in real time
or other terminal inside or outside the
lab if you have a configured right so
there is a huge number of way there's
several ways you can access the data
with darts so you can create a heaven
you know the dark software create lab
reports that will automatically just
expel her it into state Excel sheets and
then the report contains an embedded
link to the database so you can just
click refresh on your excel sheet and
then it will automatically populate that
sheet with the fresh data from the
report if you'd ran another asset for
example that's really convenient the
other thing you can do is you can
monitor runs in real time using the web
enables they're using the web interface
so it's art will report out with the
method is running how long it's been
running you can query all the various
sorts of lab where and find out what's
been done and gooses who's been doing
run and you can use it to generate all
kinds of reports so on the top left
we've got the what the query builder
looks like and you can include any
basically if you're building a report
out it is just a matter of clicking
which fields you want to include in the
report and so above for example I've got
an illustration where you're using dart
to report data out to the illuminant
experiment manager for your sample sheet
generation including the sample and
which I five and I seven indices of been
associated with which library and on the
left on the bottom there we have
you know the library normalization
report in dart to point out where we're
going to work showing what the starting
concentration was how much volume was
moved and what the normalization
concentration was afterwards so it
allows you a variety of ways of getting
access to your data and storing it so so
finally I wanted to just go over some of
our our application card so we've got
website with link you can see above I
info got beckman coulter comps lessons
yes and there you'll find our current
NGS library preparation method card so
this method card will detail what
methods we've effort we've we've
developed what applications we've
developed on which platforms there's
this process this lists continually
growing and we're actively adding
content to it on a complete model seems
like on a daily basis these days so I
strongly encourage any of any and all of
you to to go ahead and fit over to this
website and for more information so
finally I just wanted to invite anyone
to send us questions via the Q&A tab and
thank you for attending it's been a
pleasure speaking with you thank you
David and Zach for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box down by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window David's death
will answer as many questions as time
permits the first question is for the
Vitamix capable of the 384 format is
there a 384-well head or are you
pipetting for time with a 96-well head
and further 10 the 96th head pipette
individual volume ok so i can answer
their questions did
the answer is yes the biomech do have
options for either in 96 or three four
wheel head as far as the second part of
the question that the heads cannot cut
that individual volumes as a 96 or
384-well transfer however we do have the
enhanced like this tip pipetting heads
which are capable of doing individual
row column or individual well type
heading so if you did have a 96 or
384-well lab word format that require
different volumes in different wells you
could use the enhanced selective tip
feature to either deliver or aspirate
off different volumes from different
wells within that 96 or 384-well lab
work how long does it take to implement
an existing method with no modifications
versus one with modification yeah I can
make that so typically what we found
when we installed methods that usually
there will have to be some sort of
modification into it what is deployed we
will have a customer want to change
which pcr plate that is being used for
example or they'll have others some of
the requirements say for example in the
case of lasted or working in a clinical
environment they don't want to reuse
tips so we will have to provide a
reconfiguration for that if you have no
modifications to make it's literally a
matter of importing the method into your
environment controller which takes all
of about 30 seconds and then mapping it
onto the customer deck which again does
not take very much time and then we will
go through the process of validating the
pipetting and doing the water test run
and that depend largely on the
complications are how complex about the
protocol so for true Sikh pcr free with
no modification
it would be approximately two days with
no changes but it might be you know more
than that assuming that we needed to
make some modifications can any of the
biomass process any kind of genomics
kits yes our our automation is chemistry
agnostic so we can provide as automation
solutions for aluminum Biolabs the
Rubicon Swift other you know vendors
that may may not be more petite so we
also have a variety of extraction
chemistry that we sell ourselves
including the form of pure a day advance
and RNA advance and we can certainly get
you more information on those if you're
interested how do I get support for
excelling methods not on your list do I
need to wait until your team provides
them like I say this one so we do have a
pre exhaust exhausted list of
applications that are demonstrated or
qualified but if you happen to have a
requirement for an application that's
not on the list then we do have feel
team that covers the US but globally
actually to be able to handle those
specific needs and develop methods out
in the field so a lot of times to be the
voice of customer and market research
that I talked about earlier actually
comes from our field teams so they're
not working with the customers every day
and method application development could
actually start in the field and it does
quite often so they will develop those
methods and then route them through the
internal group and allow us to kind of
add additional features the UI options
etc that will then be able to be
utilized by by many labs and in addition
in further the the collaborative support
that we have for the in-house
development of
occasions extends out to methods that
were developed in the field so if if a
customer wants the particular vendors
chemistry field application scientists
developed it then those vendors do
partner work closely with us to ensure
that customers results are optimized for
feel developed methods as well how often
do you add message to your menu seems
like weekly so we're in the mean just in
the last few weeks we've added five
applications to the repository that we
got a source the method card from so
that our development process is
continuous and it's mostly based on
market demand so we have a focus on
providing more solutions for small lab
now so you'll see an increase in the
cadence of violent 4,000 and
biomechanics p methods what's the type
heading volume range for your systems I
can handle Evan too so for the
bottleneck 4000 we can type at anywhere
from 1 to 1,000 microliters depending on
that and depending on the tip that's
loaded and excuse for a one microliter
transfer or a p20 tip though the
precision is in accuracy is five percent
for ap1000 tip for a 1000 my Twitter
transfer it's two percent in accuracy
for our spanning systems we can pipe it
accurately down to half a microliter
with an accuracy of approximately five
percent we do actually have a
application note around that that we can
certainly add give to people if they're
interested in seeing some of the data is
there any project to get low retention
tips from beckman I can answer that
basically are the plastic that we use is
it's always get big old virgin
polystyrene it's not recycled and the
tips are all of our tips are essentially
spect out
retention and a lot of the pipetting
optimization also increases the recovery
from samples and liquids within the tip
so for viscous liquids slower pipetting
helps deliver controlled controlled
delivery of the viscous liquids ensures
optimal recovery again all of our pits
are considered to be low retention menu
rink the sample tracking to lab guru oh
that's a good question i'm looking at
lab guru now and some okay i don't see
why not a long wagner was able to handle
the csv formatted file that the sample
tracking could to generate i would need
to know specifically more about that
particular application before I could
get Aubree with you know a solid yes or
no okay give us a moment to see the
additional questions are flowing in hang
on one second so what is the sterile
barrier of the tips is the barrier a
filter or other kind of technology yes I
can answer that one so it is a filter
and it's made of polyethylene and it is
does an excellent job of keeping your
pipe and repeating year with hammers
from getting contaminated by your
products the Assembly of the filter is a
sterilized add the product so after the
barriers inserted the whole concert is
sterilized
very well so um i would like to once
again thank david harvest and zach smith
for their presentations do you have any
final comments for us today just thank
you everyone for attending it's been a
pleasure speaking with you and if you
have any further questions or comments
please get in touch with us we'd be
happy to hear from you alright and we'd
love to have you join us again on parts
to in part three of our webinar series
again those are titled DNA and RNA
sequencing sample prep for part two that
will take place on Thursday June 23rd
same time and part three Jim is entitled
mission possible automating NGS sample
prep for challenging samples and nisha
applications and that will take place on
Thursday July 28 at the same time eight
o'clock a.m. pacific and 11 eastern i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
question we'd also like to thank our
sponsor Beckman cultural life sciences
for underwriting today's educational web
cast as a reminder in case some of you
missed what the speakers just told you
the webinar is first part of a three
part series so save the dates for the
upcoming presentation part two DNA and
RNA sequencing sample prep automating
simple to complex methods will be
presented on june 23rd in part 3 mission
possible automating NGS sample prep for
challenging samples and niche
applications will be presented on july
28 registration is now open from both of
these webinars so feel free to visit the
lab roots website to confirm your
attendance today this webinar has been
approved for continuing education
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on demand through
november 19 2016 lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live events until next
time bye